avait donné rendez vous en début d'après
midi hier il avait fait monter la
pression il avait promis des révélations
des documents les gens ils se sont
pressés hier la fédération des sports de
glace didier gailhaguet accusé d'avoir
couvert les agissements de gildas hier
s'était livré ces livres est une contre
offensive en règle avec une heure et
demie deux conférences de presse on
écoute ça depuis quand dans ce pays at
on supprimé la présomption d'innocence
la fédération est accusé sur la base de
médias pour le moins déchaîné une
ministre moralisatrice et selon les
opportunistes de circonstances qu'on n'a
pas vu d'ailleurs dans les patinoires
depuis certains près de dix ans avec
quelques arrière-pensées électoralistes
alors j smadja ça c'est pour vous non
vous avez été dans des cabines a misé
des sports racontez nous comment ça
s'est passé à l'époque et finalement
comment vous pour répondre aux
accusations de marie george buffet qui a
dit a dit gagné préparer votre défense
elle a totalement raison
au début de l'année 2000 nous avons reçu
un courrier
la fédération française des sports de
glace qui était présidée par monsieur
gailhaguet envoie au ministère fait
suivre au ministère un courrier qui
émane de parents d'une patineuse de haut
niveau qui se plaint des agissements de
monsieur b hier à son encontre
voilà l accuse de certain nombre d'actes
que vous pouvez imaginer et donc la
première réaction de la limite de
l'agression
concrètement oui oui la première
réaction de la ministre marie george
buffet à ce moment là c'est de
déclencher une enquête confiée une
enquête interne confiée à l'inspection
générale du ministère de la jeunesse et
des sports cette enquête a lieu dans les
semaines qui suivent
elle conclut à la nécessité de suspendre
monsieur beyer ce que la ministre fait
immédiatement le dossier est transmis au
parquet à la justice la justice ne
donnera pas suite à ce dossier donc des
poursuites ne seront pas engagés en tout
état de cause
monsieur gailhaguet il a eu connaissance
du rapport de l'inspection générale
jeunesse et sport qui met clairement en
cause pour un certain nombre
d'agissements monsieur beyer et donc
monsieur gailhaguet en tant que
président de la fédération
il l'aurait dû c'était son devoir de
prendre des dispositions pour écarter
monsieur beyer de tout contact avec avec
les jeunes patineuses avec ce monde il
aurait dû les cartes et la faire non
seulement il ne l'a pas fait à ce que
cette époque-là micheline landes
concrètement des choses la ministre a
suspendu monsieur beer elle a suspendu
il ya ensuite si vous voulez la justice
vous savez c'est long la justice a
décidé de ne pas poursuivre la mini
madame buffet est parti en 2002 il ya eu
un autre ministre qui lui a succédé
bon qu'est ce qui s'est passé après je
n'en sais rien mais moi ce que je peux
vous dire ce dont j'ai été témoin et si
vous voulez là où monsieur gailhaguet a
fait une faute
vraiment c'est que à partir du contenu
du rapport de l'inspection il aurait dû
prendre des mesures
il aurait dû écarter monsieur beyer de
tous de toute activité au sein de la
fédération
non seulement il ne l'a pas fait
attendre mais pire encore
mais pire encore c'est que au fur et à
mesure du temps et au fur et à mesure
qu'on a oublié cette histoire il a pris
du galon monsieur b hier et jusqu'à
devenir en 2018 un des membres de la
direction de la fédération française des
sports de glace
alors pourquoi il ne l'a pas fait vous
savez le la fédération et il est rare de
glace comme beaucoup de fédérations
sportives
c'est un tout petit monde mais un tout
petit monde tout le monde se connaît il
ya un de vos confrères qui parlait hier
ou avant-hier de consanguinité
c'est pas faux pour pour dire un peu
l'ambiance tout le monde se connaît il
est impossible il est totalement
impossible que monsieur gailhaguet n'ai
pas eu connaissance des accusations qui
traînait dans ce milieu de la fédération
à l'encontre de monsieur biya c'est
totalement impossible à ce que vous
dites c'est que lui savait et que tout
le monde savait oui bien sûr bien sûr
que je dis bien sûr il ya bien sûr qu'il
savait et bien sûr qu'il n'a il n'a pas
eu le courage ou parce que ça
l'intéressé y est que monsieur b hier
parce que vous savez il ya beaucoup de
d'écurie au sein d'une fédération
on est pour intel on se bat pour
empêcher un tel de devenir président
c'est la fédération française des sports
de glace c1 c'est un combat permanent de
chef pour essayer de détrôner l'un fait
remplacer l'autre en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que fédération c'est
généralisable le monde du sport en
france n'ont cessé spécifique aux
fédérations qui n'ont petits ne sont pas
forcément des faits ration de masse vous
ne trouverez pas forcément cette
ambiance dans la fédération française de
football ou dans des fédérations qui on
n'a pas l'air tout à fait à l'abri
pataud licenciés non mais non mais vous
savez je crois que là ce qui est en
train de se passer
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que là
il ya une parole qui se libère et vous
verrez on en est qu'au tout début on en
est qu'au tout début
parce que il faut bien voir que ces
jeunes sportives qui veulent accéder au
haut niveau
elles sont totalement vulnérable elles
ont un rapport extrêmement individuel
avec leur entraîneur et ce qui est
scandaleuse qui est ignoble c'est qu'un
certain nombre alors heureusement pas
tous mais un certain nombre
d'entraîneurs se comportent comme des
prédateurs et il utilise cette relation
de dépendance avec leur avec leurs
sportives pour justement avoir des actes
qui sont et il faut absolument qu est ce
que vous décrivez est malgré tout c'est
un système c'est à dire c'est une
pratique
qui part par absence de mesures par
absence de sanction par absence de
mesures claires et tout c'est une
pratique qui a bénéficié d'une certaine
mansuétude et qui s'est banalisée et en
gros ben il ya un certain nombre de
d'entraîneur de cadre technique dans
divers sports qui considéraient qu'il
pouvait se permettre ce genre d'attitude
que ça n'aurait pas de conséquence est
que voilà et ça faisait partie un petit
peu et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument que je serai là vous avez
d'autres suspects asie et bien
surveillance est très bien il ya eu des
affaires dans le milieu de l'athlétisme
mais il y en a eu dans le milieu du
tennis voilà donc on sait notamment liés
oui c'est notamment liés si vous voulez
c'est quand le sport est individualisé
que le problème est quand on est dans
des sports individuels vous avez une
relation totalement personnaliser la
natation personnalisé à l'athlète
là il ya un risque il y à il y un risque
il faut absolument protéger ces jeunes
sportives
il faut les protéger il faut les il faut
faire en sorte que de tels agissements
ne puisse pas avoir lieu il faut les
faut les informer il faut les protéger
il faut il faut que la honte change de
camp ça c'est très important parce
qu'ensuite elle culpabilise et du coup
elles hésitent à se demande si c'est pas
de leur faute et donc ça il faut
absolument lutter contre ça et il ya
toute une culture a créé pour que le
droit soit rétabli et que le droit c'est
le fait qu'on n'a pas le droit de
toucher à une jeune fille quand elle
fait du sport on n'a pas le droit de
sport de oui enfin non je parle du sport
parce que c'est ce milieu là dont on
parle mais voyez il faut complètement
recréé du droit recréer de la normalité
droit le droit d'exister sinon vous
l'appliquez justement nom n'a pas le
droit sous pour voir aussi souvent dans
ces milieux là on considère qu'on est un
peu hors sol considère mais c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas noyé les gagnants mais
bien sûr le droit d'exister plus il faut
faire des enfants il faut faire preuve
de fermeté et moi je salue l'attitude de
la ministre des sports oksana
maracineanu parce qu'elle fait preuve de
fermeté de courage elle dit les choses
elle a l'air déterminé à aller au bout
et moi je pense qu'il faut il faut la
soutenir dans cette démarche
didier leschi alors je crois qu'il ya
bernanke il vous disait
la littérature était plus importante
quand il disait il ya une époque où
finalement seule la littérature conteste
finalement il ya aussi en jeu une époque
où non pas du tout ou c'est un je crois
qu'il faut en tout cas on peut pas
raisonner justement vous dit la chaîne a
conquis ce qui est frappant dans le dos
dans l'attitude du président de la
fédération des sports de glace et qu'il
a aucune compassion pour les victimes
je veux dire il n'y a aucun discours il
dit même pas il va falloir qu'on regarde
très précisément ce qui s'est passé à
l'intérieur de de notre fédération du
rapport ont exprimé des regrets
il a pas semblé des c'est pas simplement
c'est pas des relais de dix prix fort
non il a plaidé l'erreur ne s'est pas
simplement l'erreur c'est la remise en
cause d'un système qui fait qu'il peut y
avoir une relation individuelle entre un
entraîneur il ya un athlète et aider
avec des dérives possibles qui sont des
dérives à caractère sectaire enfin me
sens bien je ne peux pas nier trop il
peut pas dire autre chose il ya trente
ans qu'il est patron de cette fédération
je vais par intermittence donc
effectivement s'il ya un système qui
existe ça veut dire qu'il en a forcément
été informé d'une manière ou d'une autre
au cours de ce temps et donc il l'a
couvert et qu'il en est responsable le
spot matin la seule entité de ce type où
les personnes peuvent se
déresponsabiliser on serait dans une
collectivité locale
on aura une affaire comme ça avec des
employés y en ai lu on dirait oui mais
est-ce que le avec un maître juin d'un
maire est ce qu'on dirait le maire voilà
il peut s'en sortir comme ça en dix ans
j'ai pas regardé je ne savais pas tout
ça et c'est la presse qui me le révèle
en france on serait tous là en disant
c'est pas un type qui a démissionné en
janvier qu'elle égale à 80%
je sais pas j'ai sincèrement je ne sais
pas je suis extrêmement contente de voir
qui on a aujourd'hui la possibilité de
l'ouverture de la parole pour pour ces
sportifs je pense que c'est je pense que
c'est cathartique pour elle j'espère en
tout cas que ça l'est j'espère que ça
les aidera à se reconstruire je pense
que c'est urgent urgentissime de
s'intéresser aux différentes à toutes
ces faits des dons vous parliez sur les
sports notamment individuelles avec des
relations très particulières à
l'entraîneur parce que c'est
probablement pas les seuls et j'espère
que ça va ouvrir d'autres paroles moi
j'ai un tout petit truc de vingt deux
choses qui m'ont un peu interpellé café
la justice c'est à dire vous dites que
du coup vous avez transférer le dossier
ça me choque énormément qu'il n'y ait
pas eu de suivi alors est-ce que c'était
par manque de preuves je sais pas mais
là il ya une vraie faille quelque part
dans la justice kim qui m'interpelle
énormément et la deuxième chose c'est
que les frais n'étaient pas ces
consistant que y'avait pas je sais pas
c'est à dire que c'est gagné on peut
peut-être pas l'accuser de de ce que ces
femmes accusent leur entraîneur mais il
ya un pourrait penser et je ne suis pas
la justice pour ça je le vois on
pourrait penser à un homme assistance à
personne en danger
ne serait-ce que ça et moi je lis un
autre truc alors là je n'aurai d'accord
peut-être c'est j'ai un peu de mal avec
le tribunal médiatique
de manière générale
alors on n'avait pas de témoignages qui
est quand même un témoignage de
l'intérieur donc c'était plus facile de
dire ça à ce moment là vous l'avez vécu
il ya quand même un certain nombre de
faits qui me paraissent s'avérer qui
voit là mais néanmoins on a une justice
qui existe je pense que le sujet il est
surtout là en fait il faut qu'on
renforce la justice de ce côté là il
faut qu on donne beaucoup plus de moyens
la justice pour pouvoir s'occuper
correctement de ces femmes là et à tout
le personnel judiciaire tout autour
parce que on parle de la justice mais on
va parler aussi de la manière dont
étaient accueillis on peut parler aussi
de la manière dont tu es un curseur
aussi les témoignages intel ou une
mineure sur l'accompagnement et c'était
extra et je trouve que je sais pas ce
que doit faire monsieur gay gay ce n'est
pas à moi de décider et ce n'est pas à
moi mettre une opinion voilà un jugement
par contre il ya un vrai sujet sur la
justice de ce côté merci beaucoup les
choses je note que ça au moins sur ce
sujet vous reveniez il nous reste
quelques milles pour aborder notre tout
dernier sujet qui est très léger on fera
juste un petit tour de table
c'est le la
municipal et puis l'écologie planter des
arbres développer le vélo généralisée
des cantines bio voilà les propositions
fleurissent et les candidats aux
municipales et puis la dernière en date
c'est cette idée cette proposition de
loi de jean battault de d'interdire les
panneaux publicitaires
on voit à l'écran sont la proposition de
loi l'extrait un panneau numérique de 2
mètres carrés consomme 7 1000 kilowatts
par an soit la consommation annuelle
d'un foyers avec enfants
nous nous dirigeons vers un monde moche
et uniformiser où la publicité est
partout tout autour de nous alors est-ce
qu'elle a raison est-ce qu'elle a tort
qu est-ce que c'est du gadget qu'est ce
que vous feriez qu'en tant que des
responsables voilà alors qu'est ce que
vous allez faire ça fait mais déjà il
faut savoir que s'ils commune veut
interdire la publicité sur son
territoire elle peut le faire elle a les
outils juridiques pour le faire ça
s'appelle laurent
ça s'appelle le règlement local de
publicité alors oui mais alors on n'a
pas interdit totalité mais on a
considérablement restreint il y a
aujourd'hui très très peu de panneaux
publicitaires sur le territoire de
nanterre est par exemple vous pouvez
vérifier jeux olympiques tous les ans
placé les noms on peut il faut limiter
non mais elle a raison sur ce sur cet
aspect là notamment
je pense qu'un truc qu'il faut pas
laisser se développer c'est la publicité
vidéo c'est ça c'est ça c'est
extrêmement c'est une pollution
lumineuse pollution d'énergie et puis ça
c'est vrai que c'est laid dans le pays'
dans le paysage urbain en frais papier
ça veut dire non mais attendez il faut
quand même il faut aussi éviter d'être
trop me